hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don Sakia today we're sitting
down at Co Fez at the Congress on the
future of engineering software and we're
sitting down with pink Phu thank you so
much for coming on yeah yeah sure I
appreciate it and ping is a
chinese-american entrepreneur she is an
author
she has founded geo geo magic and then
sold it to 3d systems yes so we will be
chatting a little bit about some history
will be shining a little bit about
computer aided design and the importance
of that and I'm really grateful for you
to taffy on thank you yeah let's get
started so what is this story the story
was you were born in China and the new
[ __ ] you dropped a lot of crazy stuff on
to me just a little couple minutes ago
because I'm very familiar with or I'm
somewhat familiar with the one-child
policy in China but you were really
tapping into understanding that and
discussing it and then oh then you move
to the US so maybe tell us a little bit
about your early earlier life yeah so
it's a long story I'm gonna give you a
shorter version you know I was born in
China and in when I was 8 years old
Cultural Revolution started and that's
the biggest social approval in China so
when I was 8 school were closed and I
was raised by my aunt and my my mother
lives in a different City but in one day
of 1966
I lost the mother who raised me the
mother who give my purse and I became a
surrogate mother of my younger sister so
both set up my parents were sent to
remote area in exile so I grew up with
my younger sister who's 4 I was 8
there's no parents no school I learned a
lot of skills by being just a maker
myself and
and cultural evolution ended 10 years
later and then I went to college in 1978
studied Chinese literature before
graduation I did some research
infanticide killing off baby girls based
on one-child policy and let's let's go
back a bit to the Cultural Revolution
for those that don't know can you tell
us a little bit about what had occurred
that caused you to lose your mother to
exile and that you had to be raised by
just your sister together at such a
young age what was going on in China at
the time it mal was the head of the
Communist Party was losing popularity
and it's kind of a political struggle
and then he enabled all the use and tell
them you are the northern master of the
country and that purged what's called
the five elements those other people who
are educated or entrepreneurs or owns
the land land owners for anyway who may
have been successful through either
business or education were purged and
they use teenagers or rise up to around
the country those out what's called the
Red Guards and so the country being
turned upside down all of the school are
closed and we didn't know it was gonna
last for ten years we thought maybe be
tomorrow we'd be back a few years yeah
thirty to forty million people were
purged three million people killed many
of them our country's leaders and since
both of my parents were educated they
were sent to remote China Wow so
everybody that is educated land owning
entrepreneurial because they were aware
that they were saying mouths not good we
don't want to measure leader then Mao
sent them to exile because of he wanted
the youth to come in and say that oh no
because I to control easier to control
easier to manipulate 3040 million people
were exiled were purged from their land
and was it done by military force
well the Red Guard become the military
force kind of like yeah I don't want to
say Hitler engage the use but it it's
not quite like that because it's much
much broader because the use being put
in that position don't necessarily want
it to do some of the atrocity that they
cost like it they also don't have school
so I like to say the victims or the ones
to have done some of harsh things both
our victims doing that kind of in how
did the children decide to either go
with their parents in exile or you don't
have any decision you have kind of they
just kept the children where they where
were in dormitories ya know where we
we're not going with the parents we just
lived with our parents
when was it the next time that you saw
your mother father I didn't see my
father until I was 20 I didn't see my
mother until I was 13 it happened when I
was 8 wow this is so crazy and so close
I was only 50 years ago yeah yeah it's
only 50 years ago yeah
there are so many many children were in
that situation so about 30 or 40 million
children ish were in that sense the
meaning of total population yeah and
then those people's children so it was
probably about that many children got
put into this position Wow and then how
did that how did that end up coming to a
close that 10-year period when people in
Excel could come back to mod I'd Mao
died and then wynjym this is deaf
natural yeah natural - he was in his
eighties he died of illness and then
court Revolution counter and it still
took like two years of residual before
the school actually reopened that
ecology opened and the people that were
in Excel could come back to the cities
not all of them came back some came back
some didn't come back some stayed out
there yeah
because some of them when they're young
they got married they have children they
stayed out there many of them come back
Wow and so you were then studying a
Chinese literature mm-hmm and you were
also covering part of the the the the
one-child policy as well I was it's my
last semester I was going to graduate I
wanted to be a reporter and so I was
thinking of doing graduate school in
journalism and to do graduate school you
need to do a thesis I picked this topic
off one-child policy
as my thesis topic because it was at the
time it was at the peak of one child
policy and a timeline of the one-child
policy the one-child policy started in
1978 by 1982 which is when I was doing
research it was at its peak and its peak
means that it's it was so strictly
enforced they become inhuman ya know for
me I just knew one child policy was he
was promoted everywhere because big like
posters everywhere so I thought oh that
would be a good topic to do researcher
but when I went to do this research I
realized that girls being killed because
the farmers wants boys and I sing
hundreds and hundreds of baby being
killed by even throwing to the dumpster
or throwing into the river when they're
in Bali and embellish port is still
fresh so it broke my heart then I
started to do more research and I
realized there's a woman who lost their
babies are being forced to have abortion
when they're nine months pregnant have
nowhere to go like even just me asking
them and I haven't them telling me their
story was such a comfort even maybe I
have no chance to pass
this mm-hmm but just that they have
someone that can tell about their loss
was a comfort I was 23 I have all this
woman crying on my shoulder so I keep
doing it I missed a lot of school days
and I got punished for missing school my
research was taking away and I was
arrested on campus and putting jail and
I thought I was gonna die
but fortunately Cultural Revolution was
over more has died already and I didn't
get killed I was giving the choice of
either leave the country or being
excited to remote area I saw leaving
would be safer yes so I applied many
countries Japan congri American like I
got visa to us first mm-hmm so that's
how I landed in u.s. in 1984 so this is
so when the Chinese one-child policy
started in 78 and it peaked around 82
when there were billboards around
showing to only have one kid families
were choosing to have a male child
because of agriculture and because of
the lineage you were teaching me as well
because your lineage would stop if you
had a female child because then they
would take the last name of the of the
man that they marry so and you had all
these cases this this is very this is
very important because we have the
example that you listed earlier with
your family not actually seeing them a
for a period of five years or ten years
with your mom and dad and then you have
this period of time where you have women
that have to give the 9-month in
abortion because they were having a
female child they were crying on your
shoulder they were how they just wanted
to talk to somebody about this I was
loving and caring for them these are two
very crazy things to have happen to
somebody when they were 10 years old 20
years old
you must have learned and grown so much
from such a young age well that's I like
to say like I have this mother instincts
you have been surrogate mother to my
sister when I was eight years old you
know getting into mothers crying losing
that baby and then losing my own mother
somehow developed this empathy and
compassion as a mother yeah and I always
felt like being a CEO up in your mother
I would be more proud of being a great
mother than being a great CEO and I also
applied a lot of mother hood like
mother's love mother's tough love
mothers caring mothers compassion
mothers safe you know that kind of
principle in my business it has always
been there and you actually ended up
when you move to the u.s. later on you
ended up you ended up publishing a book
about this the bend not break a life in
two worlds mm-hmm and so this was the
book in published in 2013 outlying
outlining some of the stories from 82
that you experienced and then that went
on until about you said just last year
the one-child policy
six 2017 it took until 2017 so that was
a third 40 years yeah almost 40 years 40
years and and last time I read it was
that it prevented about 400 million
total births was prevented from it and
then and then you said you were you were
teaching me that it was about I mean
there was a major imbalance at that time
then between the amount of of met of
males that were being born in comparison
to women about a 40 million there was a
missing girls are missing uh-huh so not
all of which were killed and because
after my atrocity of being reporting
this infanticide and
export you know being kicked out of
China the issue actually came up open
not the Chinese government didn't want
people to kill baby girls either so they
actually opened the door for adoption
yes and so 40 million girls missing in
terms of imbalance many of them were
adopted yes and there were still several
million killed as well that's at least
four million plus four million plus
kills come in and then the 30 or so plus
million that went out for adoption were
to other countries or others that that
kind of other countries and then that
would enable your family to try for a
boy then to try having a boy well I
think it's yeah it's it's better than
being guilty yeah I feel like even
though that I was got in trouble for
that I feel a sense of pride of having a
lot of girls being saved their life
being saved because of that what was
what was the enforcement like how did
they know oh it's that's a really good
question so one of the things in China
is neighborhood watch
so everybody watches everyone by 82 when
I was say it seems peak a woman actually
have to be checked at that they have
period and so there are some woman who
cheats and then they would use someone
else's period to show that they have
purely they're not pregnant my gosh and
so they would actually have it was one
of the things I'll rage the Chinese
because I wrote about a finger check
like you have to use your own finger to
show that you have a blood with your
fingerprint no no you touch yourself to
show you yet period because otherwise
they cheat they show a path that's not
this to show they're not pregnant and
they're not not pregnant so this is what
I mean by being in the peak it you have
to submit yourself to do a check every
knock we got a doctor that was on the
lot neighbor just a neighborhood doesn't
have to be doctor just neighborhood
watch
so I wrote about that and then the count
you know the people the propaganda
office come to attack me and they use
this example and then the entire nation
was angry they think I shame them but
this was the truth it it happened yeah
and and then we had there's also the
visual the visual of the stomach as well
that they can see even if you are
they're trying to submit a period to
yeah yes we get past it
well if you are pregnant you would be
forced to do a potion I found woman
there was pic and then like literally
eat and it was pic hiding on the plan
scene for entire pregnancy and only end
up with still baby because they are so
not educated they don't know the pic
food had alcohol in there like sad
stories I've seen so many sad stories of
how people tried to have second baby and
then what they extend they would do to
half the second baby not it's allowed to
have two babies but back then the thing
for me was very strict later was small
less but when I did my research that was
quite severe we are very grateful that
you were given a visa by the u.s. to
come here and that you weren't
imprisoned and that you were able to
come here and not this is not rot away
in prison it was very important that you
continue to live I'm grateful I'm
grateful to have this life I I can't
like I can pinch myself to here hope to
see you back for you yeah okay and then
you come to the United States and then
how did you get involved in
computer-aided design and engineering
how did this all well I started with
computer signs right because I didn't
have enough English to study Chinese
literature and I found computer science
and the person who explained to me he
said Oh literature is writing essay for
people to read
Computer Sciences writing code for
people to use yeah I was thinking I'm a
pretty good writer and I can do this and
then I realized it has nothing to do
with writing so I told myself I mean I
have to inspire myself to continue I
said okay I'm writing the code for the
future not yet imagined so that's me
when I got good inspiration yes so I
continued in design mode for the future
not yet imagined yeah yes so that's all
right I like inspired myself to continue
to to write a code today I will tell
people writing code is also writing yes
we all learn read and write you know as
soon as we get to kindergarten and don't
be scared off writing code because it's
just a form of writing and that makes it
less nerdy it's just a form of writing
it's just form of writing yes yes
actually people who write code are very
creative yes absolutely yeah and so then
I'm going to continue on on this on this
journey you were inspired to write code
for people to use yes sir and then I
when I when I gone through school I
worked because I have to pay all state
tuition I have no parents no friends
here or were you at the time I was
initially studied in University of New
Mexico and that was when I study is
English a second language then I went to
University of California San Diego for
computer science okay and graduate there
while I was in San Diego I met an
entrepreneur his name is LAN Sherman and
has a database company so I I was
studying in a work at his company and he
was doing database software for lawyers
and nonprofits and so I learned a lot
about entrepreneurship because he was
intrapreneur he was raising money and it
was very early then I graduated I got
offer from Bell Labs and interesting the
AT&T Bell Labs was the only company I
heard of when I was in China because
everybody said Bell Labs has more Nobel
Prize
- then anybody else anyway so I always
wanted to work for Bell Labs I joined
Bell Labs and worked on networking
database object oriented programming in
C++ all very early
ran and then while I was doing that I
kind of got little bored
where's mid 80 that was late 80 waited
late 80 and then I was doing my master
why I was at Bell Labs and then I met my
ex-husband and he teaches at University
of Illinois urbana-champaign so I
followed him down to a management a
enjoined NCSA National Center for
supercomputing applications mm-hmm and
the first project I worked on was
computer animation for Terminator 2
Judgment Day when a t-1000 male down to
a Pato it's like I feel like I found my
calling because it's art meets science
yeah I really love yeah and also I'm at
the place where sky's limit you don't
have to worry about profit or making
money you can just do something
interesting
that was so great exactly yeah and and I
applied an SF Grant and I had some
grants I have some graduate student and
then this young students sophomore his
name is Mark Andrews and showed up and
wanted a job and and he said he was at
IBM Austin and learn how to do graphic
user interface and a crime graphic user
interface with some very forward concept
so I say yeah okay so I hired him and he
was in my group for three years and then
he wanted to do browser and then there
were a few other students Eric bina and
so on that was seven of them and they
started to do browser they did it on
Macintosh and when we MPC and UNIX so we
had all multi-platform we also at that
time we're very forward of thinking of
multi-platform software we have a
software called collage which works on
all software but mosaic is the one
had the runaway success yeah we also did
HTTP server we have telnet imaging
software we did a lot of like iconic
early stage software in that group
called a software development group yeah
I was really fun at the University of
Illinois University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign and at the
supercomputing it's called a National
Center for supercomputing applications
NCS sa so original mosaic is NCSA mosaic
mm-hm and then so with with having Mark
Anderson as a student kind of being a
part of helping out with the being a
major part in helping out with mosaic
end up coming into into our world you
also were teaching me about the
importance of open source and Apache
yeah can you elaborate on that a bit for
us
setting having having someone access a
server a free of cost rather than
everybody having their own cost
associated with you accessing their
server right so one Netscape went public
and they had a seven billion dollars
valuation with no revenue that was
unheard of back then yeah and the word
is really just rising up and the
internet above all started a year later
in 1996 everybody realized you can't
make money from from browser because
even though browser was accessed by so
many people but there's no money to be
made and then people start looking at a
server as a way to commercially make
money and we realized that because our
mission was to have a free access of
information not just free but framings
doesn't necessary mean money but it
means your ability to access information
anywhere in the world right we want the
information flow lis travel on any
server know if the commercial company
started to block the server technology
everybody have their different server
then the information would not travel
freely and that was the that was the the
really the inspiration of putting the
server into public domain open source
allow everyone to use it and that's also
like today you still see HTTP server is
having to have these paywalls
yeah yeah because I actually experienced
early on one one the telecom company and
the digital television and ISDN which
didn't never took off everybody's trying
to have their own standard and therefore
it divided the information we don't do
that anymore I remember back then when I
travel from here to Europe I need a
different SIM card if I travel to Japan
the phone wouldn't work correct unless I
have a different SIM card so no actually
we don't need to do that anymore
so the freeing a lot of information to
be free and this is not to try to
prevent any for-profit company to make
money but its empower people to be able
to access information the way that we do
access today was was to go and store
brand famously said information wants to
be free
yes information is also expensive so it
posed exists yeah but I think about was
the highest achievement was to enable
that free access of information yeah and
then your work with that was you helped
enable
appache to get started and founded yeah
yeah I was out looking for like people
to license browser and then comings IBM
to found Apache and then put HTTP server
into Apache yeah and then that is so
important I love that quote about
information both wanting to be free but
also being said yeah ok and then we go
into Geomagic so then how did you get
started with Geomagic how did that come
to life well when Netscape left NCSA I
went to Hong Kong to start a mini
supercomputer when I came back and that
scape went public university got very
excited about
potential of next killer app so that was
really the time of like a Renaissance of
entrepreneurship yeah in that time I
thought about it I feel like when
technology grows comes transportation
and information are too new bigger
there's big technology that you ideally
be supported by government that
everybody had free access because
transportation in it and communication
are two fundamental technology that
changes our perception of time and space
it makes a space smaller or bigger that
makes time shorter right so that's why
big things happen when you see one
trying getting rented or airplane gets
invented or a telephone radio television
internet right those are all huge
technology that has huge scale and at
the time I didn't think that belonged to
startup companies I wanted to do
something that that I could get my hands
on giving that I grew up not in school
but I was a maker to do a software for
3d imaging a 3d printing just makes
sense to me because it it's somehow in
my blood to be very grounded there marry
a technology that I have to interact
with the reality so the 3d scanning is
capture the real world object all seeing
our people and bring it to the digital
world and 3d printing is taking the
digital design and take it to the real
woman so to have this being an order for
physical and digital is attractive so
cool that's attractive yeah
so that's why I started gel magic and I
end up working on it for 17 years then
be part of sweet assisting I work on it
another three or three plus years so
it's 20 years in my life I have always
made drastic change every 10 years this
is the longest yeah it's the longest
also because every stage changes when
you have a startup company and you have
a grown up company then you have bigger
company then
have a public company I learned so much
Johnny I love the example of being able
to take something that's physical and
bringing it into the digital space and
then taking it from the digital space
and read into the physical space that is
another 360 circle yeah yeah
so with geometric one of the big things
was to be able to take an image of
something a photo or a couple photos
before those yes and then take bring
that into your software and it would
construct it yeah that is so cool it's
so important because then you could then
add on to it take away from it and I'm
buying it align it with something yeah
exactly and then bring that into the
world
what was it most commonly used for or
what is it still most commonly used for
so there are a couple of industries that
are commercially mostly used aerospace
automotive medical devices the the other
area are archeology education design
concept anything relate to human you
know you need to start with a human form
that mechanical cat it's not very yeah
great with it but even if you have a
human form you still would have pieces
that are mechanical because things need
to function and you have hinges and
schools and so it's a combination of
nature forms with the engineering
discipline together is what makes better
product and so you said use in aerospace
and transportation and I thought that I
thought back to what you were saying
earlier about information and
transportation affecting space and time
I thought that was also very fascinating
what you're explaining there as well I
hadn't really given it that that true
thought then that much depth that is a
really good way to put it once the I
have this thing that I like to say it's
see a bird make a plane thrown away like
a coffee cup and just what that would
mean is that you see a bird and then we
make the plane that invents
the plane the engineering and design for
the plane and then nowadays people just
take the plane to their destination and
they we throw away this idea this whole
creative process we throw it away like
the coffee cup mm-hmm and there's so
much beauty in that process that
engineers and designers have to go
through in order to make these products
whether they're digital or physical in
our world that we use and that brings us
value and so you've been helping people
make these digital and physical products
bringing them to life in our world and
that's kind of one of the driving
reasons for right well you decide have
to do yeah yeah I love me I mean I love
engineering design software and I love
people who create and I love to make
ideas to be reality like I I cannot just
stay we love them yeah I cannot just
stay at a thinking stage I got the
thinking but I need to see that yes we
always talk about execution
yeah because philosophizing is good
talking's good but bringing it into our
world yeah and helping other young
people bring it into our world I also
think our hand is very intelligent so if
we only use our mind we're missing so
much of the intelligence of our body
yeah and by doing it it actually can
make it so much more Chris crystallize
your thinking it's it's almost like
writing write like Virginia Woolf said
it doesn't exist until you write it down
yeah sometimes I have this great sauce
when I want to write it's just not that
good I'm thinking I was just talking to
someone
I was so interesting but the one I want
to write it it wasn't as powerful yeah
and then the writing itself caused you
to think and rethink and and then until
if the writing is good then it become
very solid right and the maker is same
thing I can tell you make it you're
thinking is not complete yeah so then it
goes from the thinking to the writing
and to the making yeah I like those like
those steps
because usually our thought can get
completely dissolved in the world and we
lose it well this is how we write it
down and we iterate on it and we also
don't know that our salt is not complete
until we iterate it yeah we think we got
the complete salt until we try to put it
down like oh this is missing that's not
working that doesn't make sense
I don't know this that's the way you
start doing it that's why you notice
this and so what about now so 3d systems
you are you left now and so what have
you been how long ago did you leave
about 18 months ago 18 months ago so
what have you been doing the last year
and a half
what do you focused on now well so I
said I like to change drastically every
10 years and after I did the business
entrepreneurship that's 20 years I
really wanted to not working on what I
always been working on I don't want to
be in the inertia so I started by
thinking first of all I need to refresh
myself so I call that process from doing
to being instead of focusing I'm doing
focusing on being mm-hmm and that gives
me a different perspective of life a
broader view and also from knowing T to
unknown from to take my mind from don't
know I call that curiosity yeah this
knowledge is from known to known right
so so I was thinking okay
curiosity and being ever say this he
unknown to known - known as knowledge
yeah known to unknown as curiosity yes
yes it's so good so I thinks I have that
framework I I said okay I'm gonna spend
six months to 12 months to go from doing
to being to go from known to unknown
right yeah so I was doing that what were
you what were you exploring what would
unknown were you exploring well one
thing is just go back to the college
days put on a pack pack backpack and go
and not planning mhmmm not read yeah not
not to read read what I'm gonna see
and see it and see what touches me and
then rhe so I reverse the process just
to see what I know this what I know
these things I wouldn't know this
because if I know where I'm going I read
about it I have I have a lens our future
yeah if I didn't read it
then I have encountered and the
encounter prints is a price and so I
wanted that encounter I want that
surprise I want to see what I would pay
attention to that I would normally not
pay attention to so that's kind of like
going from known to oh no I have to then
ask because there are so many examples
of this in our day to day life where we
prepare ourselves for what is going to
happen even with this conversation today
I could prepare myself by you know
reading your book front to back I could
prepare myself by reading all about you
for hours and hours or one could come
into it completely cold fresh fresh and
do you have you in the same thing with
me be going to Machu Picchu you could go
and step into Machu Pichu not knowing
anything about it and have no filter
just exploring or you could go and read
all about it watch so many videos and
then go and know kind of where you want
to look what you want to do what have
you found to be the balance between
those two dichotomies what's good really
good question I think you know there's
different things
boza both have its advantage and
disadvantage and and then I have always
been a brandy person
mm-hm and I have always been like very
thorough in study and research and data
analysis all of that so I just force
myself to do the opposite it's not
necessarily better it's just different
and it's different in the way that it
allows me to have my brand and I open to
things I would otherwise not notice
that's that's that's it's about going
from known to are know right I wanna
yeah in I wanted to be in the space of
oh no I want to be in the space like I'm
18 and 25
no idea what life is in front of me but
I'm a full of hope right full of ideas
full of imagination and then go out to
the world like that and see what I find
so that was one that was not about
whether or not I I would discover
something but it's more about behavior
change it's more about yeah how do I
change my own behavior so that I'm not
always in an inertia so that was like
and you just change yourself doing that
and I also promised myself the first six
months I would not do anything that I've
done before and now we're not I would
not visit any place at being before
uh-huh so it's like all this like
putting you into the unknown how did you
not blink or breathe because yeah I
realize everything you say I set out to
do this and that's always come to
example exactly so then that's been less
18 months there's a lot of this unknown
as curiosity changing and behavior I was
in less than 18 months I did that and I
was also sitting on a lot of boards so
I've spent a 6 or 7 boards and I'm not
advice US government anymore but I'm
advising the prime minister of UAE and
last year they're developing very asked
yeah exactly I was just there last
summer I loved it there we started a lot
of things like I being on the advise
were for four years now four years ago
we started the government summit it not
becomes much bigger government
conference even more high profile than
Davos now yeah about that yeah we
started future Foundation and future
foundation is ha stating the first
publicly 3d printed house it's very
interesting we launched the first
government back the blockchain
technology personal identity yes the
last October they had the first baby on
blockchain so not from last October on
all of newborn blockchain in Yui Dubai
in Dubai Dubai yeah every child that's
born
has a certificate is after October of
last year is now blocked
cryptographically secured on the law
digital ledger and then they are
committed to put all of the government
service on blockchain by 2020 that is
that's a centralized the digital ledger
though that's centralized debt by Dubai
the personal identity is a centralized
and also distributed those it is
distributed also distributed yes okay
but with access control with limitations
and access control no because those
stations are in the mall you can it's an
open come over it's a crypto it's it's
encrypted okay and then every so there
are public key of course but the private
key is dynamically generated mm-hmm so
wow this is interesting experiment you
know we don't we don't know if you know
what glitches there would be but you
have to start it somewhere and try and I
have to try any new bone of course don't
have a history you haven't been put on
the old system it's the easiest thing to
try and do by doesn't have very high
population the government has the desire
to do it so we tried it and they can
they can play with the system and dance
with this technology more than this
hundred plus million person country can
that try and and I and I love it because
they are looking at blockchain as a
government service yes
versus a cryptocurrency gets a lot of
dark stuff there right correct that's so
that's that's what I did in Dubai which
is very interesting yeah yeah well I I
just last week we just finished
installation of Burning Man in
Smithsonian that was 18 months project
all which taking running man art to the
nation's most respected highly highly
visible Museum and it was very
interesting experience awesome yes I'm
really happy that Burning Man has a slot
now in the Smithsonian yeah
it's my year and it's a well-deserved
it's it is truly an American cultural
movement yes
asmath Sonia has the responsibility to
research exhibit and promote American
continent it was stuff as well
so this would guide me into one of our
one of the questions we like asking on
the show a lot we were talking earlier
about China and then we've been recently
talking about Dubai and the United
States Rush all these different places
across the world where do you see where
we're going
collectively how do we function in this
globalized world yeah that's a very good
question I think I think the human
evolution and then the nature mother
earth will always have its own mind
compared or not the government is trying
to control or whichever who gets elected
who's getting power they're always
trying to control that's one form of
control and then you also have nature
just does its own thing and then you
also have a human evolution just does
its own thing so I generally are my
optimist I generally have a fundament or
trust in human evolution and nature
itself and then you have all these
structures right governments and money
bank law politics and all of those and
some of the things we have no control
over some of the things we could
influence and I think all of the humans
live on this earth could can influence
our collective civilization and society
to the better and and it does it that's
not saying that we all do it and that's
not saying we all do it at the same time
either feels like an obligation to have
to want to bring something yeah are you
to the world and in general I'm not I
try to not worry about things that I
couldn't have any influence yeah because
there are so many people just complain
about that and that it's always someone
else's responsibility I hear 60 years
so people still complain that their
parents force them to do something I'm
like okay before you're 18 you have the
right to complain by your parents after
18 no you don't have the right to
complain about your parents you know
when you're 60 you said I never wanted
to be a lawyer because my parents forced
me to do what you you have a choice
along the way to be something else if
you don't want to be don't tell me your
parents force you to do that
so we all have ways to influence how our
life to be and how things are on us but
mostly we have influence to ourselves we
decide how we feel what we do today our
contribution we want to make we
definitely have influence on our own
action
I always feel care people say oh I'm too
busy to do this and not being busy it's
not a choice being busy it's a decision
you already made and priorities are as
well or you're too busy you already made
that decision it's not even a choice
because you have a choice not to be busy
right so why do you complain about your
own choice yeah so we do have control
over our own being in terms of what we
do how we feel and what we think and
then beyond what our self we can also
influence others but we influence others
only in the way of who we are if I'm a
happy person I can give happiness to
other if I'm not happy I can't yeah if
if I am a person who creates value I can
share that value yes if I don't create a
value I only suck value from somebody
else right so it's it's one of the
things we do have controls ourselves and
and then I don't want to underestimate a
person as a seat like can influence a
lot of things around you absolute that
seat have to be a healthy seed yes
secure your own oxygen mask yeah
to be able to and the seat you know grow
into tree of plants and they give more
seeds and they give you know they give
shades they give oxygen they give a lot
of things so it's like the inner
meditation management inner self first
and then be healthy seed and go and help
other seeds be healthy and you would say
that trusting in the optimism of the
natural evolution of after you become
healthy and bring value to the world so
that you bring value to the world that
would be healthy evolution I think that
that is much bigger than us our
government you know there's a Hitler
that's gone right yeah there's like
there's a lot of bad things happened Wow
yeah or yellow fever yes you know we
affected a lot of yes
yeah diseases so those things gonna
happen but I think the nature the mother
mother nature and the human as a
collective species far stronger than
much of those negative force and if
we're not we will be eliminated the
dinosaur so we better as a collective
species work together and making
tomorrow better than today
high-five again that was beautiful
yes and that also has so much to do with
what you know what you're doing today
with building some sort of value of
leveraging computer-aided design and
engineering helping other potentially
kids around the world get really excited
about taking an image or something
bringing it in adding things to it
taking away from it and building the
future building some sort of additive
value for the world and working together
as a collective do you think that we're
alone in the cosmos we're not alone in
the cosmos
we are certainly a positive force in the
cosmos I mean if you think about
engineers whether or not the people who
are making things that benefit to
humanity or people make it to so that
engineer can make things not man if it's
humanity there are a smaller group of
people who have the capability and being
trained to create and this is one of the
reason why I bring in this community for
very long
it is because this is a creative force
and creative force amplifies great
things in the world and I hope that
people working in this field or people
who used to you know the people who
create stews and who people who used to
recognize that that they are the force
of fundamental human condition yes right
we are making the fundamental human
condition better yes and then so that
they would lift their head away from the
computers from time to time and take a
deep breath and be proud of what they do
and also going out there to see the
world to see to interact with people to
really understand what makes our
civilization our species better and
really making tools you know evolve
those tools to make it better and this
is why I said things like you know
imagination yeah audacity yeah right
collab collaborative yeah those are all
that concept for that we need to keep
pushing yeah what are these fundamental
truths and both pushing them forward
into the future do you think we're in a
computer simulation thing that's a
really good question you know I really
think that our entire universe is in
your computer's image simulation now
maybe I couldn't say that hundred years
ago but now like you cannot separate our
physical life from a digital life
anymore
because every day those data going
everywhere yeah right like whether or
not you're checking you fly somewhere
you just do checking it goes some
computer knows all of your data and a
little about checking it's you it's
getting on the computer like I don't
even know how to live if we shut down
the computer yeah I don't know how this
would all be the economic and political
systems would just also shut down I
don't even think we can go back what's
yeah
be kind of anarchy yeah and and then so
this is why I said have we ever thought
about tree is a computer mm-hmm right
like it yeah the tree is a machine not
breathe it's a breathing machine
it's a shading machine so we cannot
imagine we can live on this earth
without trees why should we think about
living on this earth without computers
and the in reality is I'm also not sure
like people said do you believe you have
for outer space I say I do mm-hmm
we were just watching a little bit about
that I said I do and the reason is like
I'm not even sure if the earth wasn't
created by some other species why should
it be totally round yeah like nature
doesn't create wrong stuff the rocks are
not round how did it become so
intelligent I don't know I mean you can
believe in you can don't have to believe
it like do you do one believe in quantum
physics where you can be there and hear
at the same time I do I do believe
contents in physics so if I believe in
quantum physics why shouldn't I believe
that maybe there'll be some like
computers that was there millions of
years ago yeah and they even like
nowadays I used to think idea is my idea
and the idea has you I used to think
like I would say my idea and I also
worked with a lot of researchers and
then they debating who came up with this
idea for us sometimes we have true idea
similar idea happened or the person
didn't pursue this idea somebody else
put whisper for example yeah but now I
believe this this is kind of symbolic I
believe idea is out there floating in
the air it is whether or not your mind
is open to receive it yes now if my mind
is open to receive this idea it it got
in Bing it comes out and if if I'm not
open it goes somebody else yeah it flows
around and same as love it's there it's
floating around it is me as a container
it's oh it's open to receive that at
that moment or not yeah so why would I
think that's my idea
it it's just I'm at a receptor of that
idea yes and that can be an amplifier of
that idea right yes be the healthy seed
and make lots of more happy yeah that's
right well ping Fuu thank you so so much
for coming and sitting down with us we
appreciate it
you you are very wise you have a lot of
wisdom to share with our world I hope to
continue engaging and interacting with
you and building together no thanks for
the conversation thank you thank you co
Fez big shout out to Congress on future
of engineering software for having us
here having simulation here
thank you guys at home for tuning in if
you had a good time give us a like
comment subscribe we'll have some links
for ping below to her book as well as to
her companies that she's founded in the
past and share this content with other
people if he found it in richen we would
love for you to do so
and thank you Ron vargas are producing
partner thank you so much and we will
see you guys again later today or
tomorrow thank you